well this place is an insane mess this
is all my game fuel I have no time for
trash it's not trash this is all
recyclable anyway aren't you supposed to
be working on homework homework I don't
have time for that monotonous repetitive
work I am almost level 40 on world of
plastic raft I just have to collect
three more water bottles with the number
two in printed on them take them to the
high elvish recycle man sir and then
I'll be able to cast malleability three
times per day on any random encounters
be low level five these are important
things I stopped listening after you
said world's this game has educational
garbage I'd never pay attention to you
can probably help with that log on to
mom's computer I cannot believe you
talked me into this nerd stuff password
y.e.s enter oh gosh
well this is magical whoa welcome to
plaster off this please is a dump don't
you guys ever recycle recycle are you
kidding when your adventuring in your
bag of holding gets full you just gotta
drop that item these are all plastic
many of these can easily be recycled
back for more little awk not again who
is this he's floored the corpulent I
can't prove it yet but I think he's 32
and lives in his mom's basement 28 it's
my aunt's attic happy
agarose where are we Blart got us we
respond in the graveyard hello travelers
it would appear to mine eyes that thou
art experiencing difficulties who are
you greetings and salutations I am lady
Polly of myrrh and I I can't do that
anymore I'm polymer if you want to beat
Blart you need to learn how to recycle
follow me told you so this game had
better not be tricking me into being a
better person in plaster off all of our
items in loot are made of plastics but
the best players don't throw out old
loot they recycle their unwanted items
okay fine let's gather this junk up and
throw it in the recycling bin you can't
do that all these plastics are different
plastic is plastic your sister is right
again haven't you ever noticed those
numbers on the bottom of items I always
assume those were stats that only uber
nerds paid attention to you're not wrong
but those numbers also tell you the kind
of plastic that item is made of there
are seven basic types of plastic you can
usually find the number in a
triangle-shaped recycling symbol on the
bottom of the product these numbers are
the resin identification code the code
is used internationally and tells us
whether we can recycle the plastic or
not plastics are made of sheets of long
chemicals called polymers different
plastics are made of different polymers
between those sheets are plasticizer
chemicals that give plastics their
properties these chemicals can make
plastics harder softer smooth or
flexible there's a lot going on in there
Plastics one and two are the most
commonly recycled types of plastic most
types of bottles are made using plastics
one and two so types one and two can be
recycled anywhere probably but you have
to check plastics four five and six are
the next most recycled
these plastics are very common in food
wraps straws and styrofoam that people
usually throw out these plastics can be
tricky to recycle and not all areas
except them didn't you skip one yep
number three these plastics are made
with vinyl and they are rarely recycled
there's just not much demand for plastic
3 as a recyclable weren't there are
seven types of plastic correct if the
plastic doesn't fit into the other
groups or it's made of a mixture of
plastics it's a seven this plastic has
become controversial because they often
include a chemical known as BPA which
comes with health concerns if ingested
because this plastic is so inconsistent
not many recycling programs take plastic
7 in plaster a few master the magics of
recycling legend tells of a warrior that
can wield a blade made of all the
elemental plastics recycler destroyer of
wastes epic loot let's sort this plastic
well that depends what plastics can be
taken in plaster offs recycling program
you mean they don't just take it all not
in all areas every area of the country
takes different plastic numbers in their
recycling so while plastics 1 2 3 4 5
and 7 may be recyclable in Sheboygan
Wisconsin they may not take the plastic
7 in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania hey what'd
I tell you in skids about putting
plastic 7 in a recycling uh-huh they'll
throw that whole bin out even if your
area doesn't take some plastics many
grocery stores will recycle your plastic
bags and electronic stores often recycle
discs and old devices with some effort
very little should be going to the
landfill fortunately here in plaster off
we take all 7 plastics all in the same
been uh-huh didn't I say that like three
exposition heavy lectures ago yeah but
now you know why come on let's take this
plastic to the recycling forge
oh I can't believe Kimberly managed to
ruin video games this is him oh I
thought elves were like attractive with
bows and arrows and like less burgers
just like America fewer than thirty
percent of plaster off players use
recycling forges there is demand for the
material but not enough people bother
hello smithy goodness who goes there
three adventure seeking your services
sir I used to be an adventurer then I
took a high-density polyethylene arrow
to the knee we have brought the seven
elemental plastics we seek to forge so
you seek the blade of euros a best get
to it then the first thing you have to
know about plastic recycling is that you
rarely make the same thing twice if you
bring me a soda bottle I can't recycle
the materials into a new soda bottle the
materials different when i get plastics
i have to sort them by type i can't mix
type 1 plastics with type 5 plastics
then we grind the plastic into chips all
of the labels and bits of glue are in
the way at this point so we will need to
wash and bathe the chips after they dry
we melt the chips into pellets these
pellets can be used to make new items
most recycled plastics can become polar
fleece tote bags containers furniture
insulation brushes lots of things but
today in my Forge we've made recicla
destroyer our waists please Lord don't
send me back to the graveyard this
validates me as a person hahahaha too
easy stand down port back again young
maiden
behold recycler destroyer of wastes your
days of looting and polluting are done
ha a recycled blade the only way to win
in this world is to buy the newest
nicest to loot that's not going to work
forever Blart we only have so many raw
materials to make new plastics on this
planet and where do we put all the waste
this stuff just sits in a landfill
forever we don't know how long Plastics
last and some of them will these harmful
chemicals into our bodies and the
environment enough talk I agree whatever
my aunt's calling me for dinner anyway
well I have to say Allison I actually
learned a lot from that game our world
doesn't have infinite resources we need
to care about recycling it's important
to check the number on our plastics so
you can make sure that your recycling
the right materials so Allison are you
gonna recycle all this junk what you
expect me to apply a lesson from a game
to real life cycle is
large come to dinner what people are
wrong on the internet now yes aunty